americans held hostage abandoned behind
enemy lines day 45.
think of it 45 days 45 days since
hundreds and hundreds of americans their
families abandoned behind enemy lines 45
days since thousands of green card
holders people eligible to be in this
country legally were abandoned 45 days
since thousands of siv holders and their
families were abandoned and are afghan
allies and 40 days since joe biden lied
to the entire world and promised to stay
in afghanistan until every single u.s
citizen was safely out of the country
sadly that wasn't joe biden's only
blatant lie because today on capitol
hill biden's top military advisers they
contradicted him over and over and over
again
now in a moment we're going to discuss
general milley's leaking the allegations
that some are even describing as high as
treason leveled against him
first we go to our so-called
commander-in-chief remember august the
19th he told fellow democratic socialist
georgie stephanopoulos over at abc that
his military advisers did not recommend
a continued us military presence in
afghanistan this this is what joe said
listen
but your top military advisers warned
against what's drawing on this timeline
they wanted you to keep about 2500
troops no they didn't it was split
that wasn't true
that wasn't true
they didn't tell you that they wanted
troops to stay
no not at not in terms of whether we
were going to get out in a time frame
all troops
they didn't argue against that so no one
no one told your military advisor did
not tell you no we should just keep 2500
troops it's been a stable situation for
the last several years we can do that we
can continue to do that no no one said
that to me that i can recall
no no one said that to me that i can
recall according to everyone that
testified today on capitol hill under
oath they say joe biden was lying they
all told him 2500 should stay listen
i won't share my personal recommendation
to the president but i will give you my
honest opinion and my honest opinion and
view shaped my recommendation i
recommended that we maintain 2 500
troops in afghanistan general milley
it's your testimony that you recommended
2500 troops uh approximately stay in
afghanistan
um
as i've said many times before this
committee and other committees i don't
share my personal recommendations to the
president but i can tell you my personal
opinion and my assessment if that's what
you want yes please um yes my assessment
was uh
back in the fall of 20 and it remained
consistent throughout that we should
keep a steady state of 2500 and it could
bounce up to 3 500 maybe something like
that
i don't share the personal opinions i
have with the president except unless of
course your name is bob woodward or
robert costa by the way jen saki care to
circle back and explain this was joe
biden lying were you lying oh we don't
need to cover test people
uh because they're not going to be here
very long you're telling a lot of lies
in that white house watch
the president said his military
committees were split we now know that
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff general melanie
the head of centcom general mckenzie and
the commander on the ground general
miller
all recommended the president keep 2500
troops so who
in his military advisors told him it'll
be fine to pull everybody out
i'm not going to get in specific details
of who recommended what
you are saying here that military
advisers to the president said it was
okay to pull all the troops out that
it'd be fine
that's not what i said the president
pulled all u.s troops out you are saying
that there were military commanders who
advised him that that was a good idea to
pull all american troops out and that
general milley general mckenzie general
miller they said something else but the
president's top military advisers others
we won't name told them sure we can pull
everyone out that's not how these
conversations go it's a risk assessment
joe biden lied and she's spinning like a
top in other words joe biden went
against the advice and counsel of his
top military advisors and yeah he
outright lied about it but that wasn't
joe's only life because we learned a lot
today we learned that joe biden was less
than truthful in other words lying about
our so-called over-the-horizon
anti-terror capabilities in a speech on
august 31st joe bragging the united
states does not need the troops on the
ground in afghanistan in order to
maintain the fight against terrorists
and keep our country safe and that our
credibility around the world remains
totally pristine
that is a claim that biden's top
generals clearly dispute look for
yourself
our credibility has has
been gravely damaged has it not general
milley
i think that our credibility um with
allies and partners around the world and
with adversaries
uh is being intensely reviewed by them
to see which way this is going to go
and i think that damage is one word that
could be used yes is the war on terror
over
general milley
absolutely not
general mckenzie
the war in terror is not over and the
war in afghanistan is not over either as
the exit from afghanistan made the war
more challenging for us or less
challenging
with respect to continuing to try and
protect the homeland and u.s interest
abroad senator just made it more
challenging
general mueller you agree yeah
absolutely
war's not over wait joe said that he's
turned the page in that he's dealing
with the very professional and
business-like taliban that are now
killing people and torturing women and
taking away all of their rights so joe
biden was repeatedly told that our
over-the-horizon capabilities were not
sufficient another lie he was told and
he knew that afghanistan would collapse
without u.s support he knew abandoning
bagram air base in the middle of the
night would leave americans virtually
defenseless he knew the taliban was
rapidly advancing throughout the entire
country the whole world knew it they
knew it march april may june and july
and he's still bragging about the
training of the afghan military that was
collapsing before the world's eyes but
joe biden continued to rush through his
botched and very preventable withdrawal
anyway because joe wanted to brag that
he successfully ended america's longest
war and then predictably when everything
went south he just lied about all of it
which pretty much sums up the plagiarist
joe biden's entire career he's been and
remains a spineless coward zero
integrity and he lies with abandon and
speaking of integrity the chairman of
the joint chiefs while general milley is
also seemingly lacking this new book
from woodward and robert costa is all
about all but accusing millie at least
in the definition of many of betraying
this country even though they're now
defending milli meaning the authors they
would burn a leaking source like a
chairman of the joint sea chiefs i don't
think they'd want to burn that so
quickly but according to the allegations
and millie even tried to defend them
today millie promised communist china
our sworn enemy a hostile regime and two
secret phone calls he would give them a
heads up if then president trump decided
to attack
uh the way i read the constitution the
commander-in-chief that would be the
duly elected president of of the united
states under oath milly's response was
at best shifty although one point he
just pretty much outright admits that
yeah he would give him a heads up you
decide
you're quoted in the woodward book
is telling the
top
chinese communist military commander
quote if we're going to attack
i'm going to call you
ahead of time
is that true general milly
let me tell you what i actually said
that's not true
i hope that let me tell you what i
actually said senator uh what i said if
there's going to be a war
uh if there's going to be an attack
there's going to be a lot of calls and
tension ahead of time but what you're
going to get you're going to get caught
simone was that you were senator
president trump would not attack that's
your testimony this morning that is true
then why would you and i was i was
communicating
to my chinese counterpart on
instructions by the way
to de-escalate the situation
and i told him if there was going to be
an attack there'll be plenty of
communications going back and forth your
intel system is going to pick it up i
said i'll probably call you everybody'll
be calling you
i'll probably call you and tell you the
attack's coming
well that would be an admission that
would be cause for immediate dismissal
now
uh woodward and costa probably taped him
so he knew he couldn't really outright
lie maybe it's time to release those
tapes to congress one thing that millie
did fully admit to he gossips like
a mean girl in high school to use a
phrase to every single reporter in town
even though he says i don't disclose the
conversations i have with the president
unless your name is woodward or costa
then you tell them everything listen
general millie
um
yes or no to this did you talk to bob
woodard or robert costa for their book
peril
woodward yes cost or no did you talk to
carol leonic and philip rucker for their
book alone can i fix it yes
did you talk to michael bender for his
book book is frankly we did win this
election the inside story of how trump
lost yes yes why would you as the
sitting chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff talk to a reporter that's writing
a book
about a prior administration why would
that be part of your job description
well as senator blackburn said earlier
i deal with the media routinely two
three four times a week i'm talking to
the media
this would be called leaking and this
would be called revealing private
conversations with your boss how
pathetic remember general milley is the
joint chiefs of staff our highest
ranking military official why would he
be leaking to any reporters and
gossiping to reporters about his boss
how exactly is our country safer or more
secure with general milley leaking and
gossiping all over town to every
reporter that has a book deal because
apparently he talked to a lot of them
how does that advance your national
security it doesn't after today it is
clear general milley needs to resign or
be fired he absolutely needs to be
investigated for the leaks for the calls
with china whether or not he was trying
to assert the power of the president of
the united states whether or not he was
coordinating with our sworn enemy what
he had in terms of conversations with
speaker pelosi and about this botched
withdrawal from afghanistan that he is
in part responsible for hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else